[موسيقى]
وانا لابد لي ان اسالك وان اسال نفسي
لماذا تحدث هذه الامور ولماذا حدثت فجاه
واطرح هذا السؤال على نفسي اذا ما كان
الامر كان خارج نطاق الطرفين المتصارعين
وقد تكون هناك اطراف خارجيه التي تحفز
وتؤجج من اجل هذا الصراع لاننا كنا قد
وصلنا الى مرحله مفصليه للتوصل لاتفاق
ياخذنا الى حكومه ديمقراطيه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
بانه يجب فعل كل شيء من اجل خلطه الظروف
المئاتيه من اجل تحويل الامور الى الواقع
والتحدث الى الجنرال برهان والجنر الحميدي
والتحدث الى اطراف الاخرى هذه ليست فقط
مساله جنرانين فحسب مساله الشعب شعب
لديه يطمح بقياده سياسيه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
كانت هناك قدره ناجحه للقاده الافريقيين
لمعالجه الصراعات المعقده وامل ان يحدث
ذلك واراهم انهم في موضع افضل للتوصل
لاتفاقا في السودان لا شكل لدي بانه قد
يكون الامر اكثر سهوله للجنرات السودانيين
لاصغاء لزملائهم الافريقيين بدلا من
الاستماع الى الامريكيين او الاوروبيين او
غيرهم لذا فان مناشدتي
بان يتم فعل كل شيء من اجل دعم مبادره
يقودها الاتحاد الافريقي
التي تفضي الى احلال السلام
عندما كنت المفاوض الاعلى السودان عده
مرات وكنت دائما
مندهشا بحصن الضيافه والكرم في شعب
السودان كنا نرى اللاجئين من
اريتيريا واحيانا يشاطرونهم توفر لديهم من
موارد من خلال نظام يعتمد على الاخويه
النظام الرائع
ولرؤيه هذا الشعب الشجاع هذا الشعب السخي
يعاني بهذا القدر كما نراه اليوم هذا امر
يبعث على الصدمه ويزعجني للغايه
[موسيقى]